deuxième point que je venais à faire
avec vous sur la situation dans notre
département liées à la crise sanitaire
que nous connaissons tout d'abord vous
parlez des ehpad
vous le savez depuis deux semaines déjà
aucune visite n'est possible pour
protéger les résidents de ces
établissements j'ai rappelé ce matin à
l'ensemble des directeurs
d'établissements les règles absolues de
confinement pour que les personnes âgées
soient le plus protégé ce qui est une
priorité aujourd'hui pour les équipes du
département
deuxième sujet les masques ils sont
insuffisants
de nombreux professionnels ne sont pas
assez protégés aujourd'hui conseil
départemental a pris la décision cette
semaine avec d'autres départements
d'acheter 150 mille masques dès demain
matin 10 mille masques seront distribués
au foyer de protection de l'enfance à
certaines associations
je pense notamment aux aides des mères
et puis également en résidence autonomie
qui accueillent des personnes âgées
un mot aussi pour vous dire que
l'ensemble des services du département
est mobilisée je pense notamment aux
travailleurs sociaux qui aujourd'hui
sont également très attentif aux
situations de violence conjugale et
protection de l'enfance je vais
remercier également les services de
l'éducation qui prépare d'ores et déjà
la sortie de la crise le bout du tunnel
nous serons bien évidemment prêt pour
réouvrir l'ensemble des collèges je
l'espère dès le 4 mai comme le souhaite
le ministre de l'éducation nationale un
mot pour saluer également le travail
exceptionnel que font les maires et
l'ensemble des élus locaux revient que
la proximité et la meilleure réponse
dans ce type de situation les maires
connaissent chaque situation chaque
personne de leur commune et leurs
actions aujourd'hui est à saluer un
dernier mot d'actualité en début de
semaine possible traitement à base de
deet rockeur qui n'a fait l'objet de
nombreux débats la recherche et l'action
des chercheurs pas des réseaux sociaux
n'écoutez que votre médecin lui ou elle
sait mieux ce qu'il faut faire il vous
connaît il
c'est ce qu'il faudra faire si vous êtes
contaminées par le virus
la meilleure prévention et de rester
chez vous de limiter drastiquement vos
contacts uniquement à vos proches à
votre domicile
prenez soin de vous